hello everyone and welcome to game
number six of the 1971 candidates match
between Bobby Fischer and Mark taimanov
now as you've seen in my five previous
videos or even more if you've seen the
older versions marked Amano is
definitely in in in a terrible position
he lost five games in a row to Bobby and
he has to now win five games in a row to
just break even as the this is a ten
games match
so if Fischer even draws one game or
wins one more game the match is over so
that being said it's very unlikely that
marked a man of will be able to do this
or you know as this already happened
that he could have done anything there
but you know as much as he can lower the
humiliation of the Soviet Union that
will definitely go in his favor
so in this game sorry about that
Bobby again had the white pieces and
once again they go for the Sicilian he 4
and C 5 so it's very interesting in the
three games Fischer had the black pieces
two of them went for a Kings Indian
defense but for the third game Fischer
decided to go for a different line as
you remember he went for the line he
went he played against making in the
Buenos Aires tournament and which of the
white pieces atamanov always opted for
the Sicilian and they always opted for
the same line so Knight to f3 knight c6
v4c captures Knight captures and East
sixth amount of goes for the time ah no
variation night b5 by Fischer same as in
game to b6
Bishop to f4 e 5 this is all the same as
their already played in game 2 Bishop to
e3 Knight to f6 now Fischer now with
seemingly waste the tempo but it's all
very you know meaningful and now the
first move that will differentiate from
game number 2
it's a Bishop to e6 as you remember in
game 2
Queen a5 check was played and then after
Fischer blocked as the knight is no
longer pinned at the Queen is not on the
8th
we had capture screen captures on a5
captures here and Bishop back to e3 and
it was a very nice game for both of them
but Fischer was able to win it after
after that prolonged adjournment
twice
okay Bishop g5 will have Bishop to e6
Knight 1 2 C 3 a 6 as here Knight to d5
would be a threat pressuring the c7
square so a6 keeping the knight back and
the now Bishop captures on f6g captures
on f6 of course not Queen captures to
allow 97 check wins began for white so
Bishop to have six G captures on f6 and
now comes Knight to a3
we have Knight the d4 a very nice move
as time on of really once again came
really prepared for this game so b5 is
all right here pretty much an idea that
you would use in Alaska Sicilian
but here night before a prepared
variation by time on off which really is
a very troublesome for white for example
if you simply continue Bishop to c4
hoping to trade here and bring this
Knight into the game then time enough
has this beautiful pawn sacrifice
prepared d5 which opens up an attack
from the bishop to the knight on a 3 and
after Knight captures rook to c8
attacking the bishop the bishop moves
and now rook the g8 and with these two
beautiful active rooks Temenos
definitely has more than enough
compensation for the bone but Fischer
decides not to go for anything like this
instead he goes nice to see for now d5
isn't such a big deal because there is
no night on a 3/4 time on of Bishop to
attack but this is what time on of was
prepared for he pushes f5 so in early f5
this is beautiful if you can play this
would black he captures on a five-night
captors and i5 and now Bishop to d3 we
have rook to c8
the bishop captures an f5 and now as the
knight is unguarded rook captures on c4
Bishop captures on e6 and now F captures
on e6 you can see that the amount of
came really prepared
Queen to h5 being a threat but really
does nothing for wife time on of skin I
would simply castle artificially and
would be very safe on the Queen side so
after F captures any sort after F
captures on e6 Queen e2 by Fischer and
here tomorrow is still in the driver's
seat and here he played rook to d4
seemingly a very active move prevents
her from castling queenside
it's a very nice active square for the
rook but much better would have been
rook to f4
now if castling queenside would run into
queen to g5 also a very very nice move
that threatens discoveries and also
attacks the Jie du Pont and castles
Queen King side would run into rook to
g8 so this is a lot of pressure here the
Queen coming into the game would be very
unpleasant for Fischer but okay rook to
d4 was played and now Fischer containers
we have castles Queen to g5 and now rook
a to d1 Queen to a5 rook captures pawn
captures in the night Stewie for a
Bishop to e7 and here rook to d1 and
here the man of really runs into some
problems there's really no good way to
defend the d4 pawn here if you defend it
with the Bishop Knight and simply
capture and then the Queen will come and
help out with with an attack with
Queenie for attacking lead to be seven
point as well this efj I've seems like a
reasonable move but simply rook captures
on d4 nothing to do here and now there's
a double attack and against the d6 pawn
if you capture the rook 96 check picks
up the Queen the bishop on e7 is pinned
from the Queen on e2 so here Queenie 5a
defending but not for long Fischer plays
Queen to d3 we have Ruka fate and now
Queen captures on d4 Queen captures and
rook captures d5 and the night the c3
and after all is said and done once
again the amount of came really prepared
Fischer defendant really well and we are
now in the end game where Fisher is up a
pawn but okay time on who has a bishop
against a knight
so so far Fischer has been proving how a
bishop is better than a night here if
Fisher has to prove that a knight is
better than a Bishop Bishop to c5
attacking the rook rook d2 and the now
rook to f4 now we have g3 Rupe the c-4 a
roof to see three four four nine three
two and now comes the rookie for
attacking the a2 upon a three King to d7
and the now comes King G - of course
activating the King getting it away from
a dark square
b5 enter now c3 we have a five-night to
d4 and here before
and here we have a very nice moment
where Fisher really displays how strong
of a player he is and how how powerful
he was in this entire series for his
conquest of the throne Knight to b3
attacking the worship on c5 here Bishop
to b6 is played and here comes C first
captures on b4 captures in the now c4 as
the pawn on d5 is pinned we have King to
c6 and now again a very nice move
c5 of course you cannot capture if you
capture rook to c2 wins the bishop as
you cannot defend with the rug the
Knight is guarding the a5 square so
Bishop to c7 and now again
Knight to d4 check again you cannot
capture here if you capture the pawn
then you get 96 check King b6 Knight
captured screen captures and wrote
characters on d5 Fischer is up 2 points
so an easily winning endgame after
Knight d4 king the d7 was played
now comes F for keeping an eye on e5 we
have E 5 and the now comes c6 with check
King to d6 would lose you the game for
example F captures and now if King
captures you get night b5 you attack the
bishop bishop has to move now you get
rookie to check King has to move and now
c7 rope has the block simply rook to c2
and it's all over if you want to stop
promotion you have to block with the
rook rook blocks but now rook to c6
check will pick up the bishop and it's
all over
so after c6 now you cannot go here you
have to go back King to see it was
played by Tom on off and the now comes
nice to b5 opening up a discovered
attack from the roof to the d5 pawn rope
to a 2 if rook captures on d5 rook will
capture on b2
now Fischer simply pushes f5 he creates
another passed pawn bishop to d8 and now
rope to d5 capturing a pawn we have rook
captures on b2 and it was in this
position that the game was adjourned
so I don't think it's known what move
Fischer played or he put in his little
envelope probably probably a king gauge
3 but it doesn't matter as this position
is completely winning for white and it
was in fact in this position that mark
time
of resigned game sex without ever
continuing it why did he resign
how well he's done in material fever has
a much better position after he moves
away from check whatever black plays
whatever plan he chooses for example if
he starts pushing his own past porn then
comes rock to c7 now you can see that a
check is coming and this will win you
the bishop so there's really nothing to
do you can prepare to push the pawn but
after check move you can capture King
actress and now you push another pass
pawn b2 for example f7 is coming now a
queen comes into the game and white
brings also a queen into the game about
now as you can see but black has no ways
of delivering any checks D F F 1 square
is guarded by the Queen from f8 and
whatever black whatever move black plays
it will be a simple win for white for
example Ruby a Czech picking up the
Queen and it's all over Queen against
the rook easily winning but of course
tamaño knew this and after he captured
on b2 and the game was adjourned he
decided to resign this with all the
dignity in the world even though he lost
the match six to zero but yeah there is
no point in continuing this and you know
even though there are you know rumors of
some players deciding to postpone their
loss for one more day so the newspapers
for example wouldn't say he lost maybe
they would say it over the weekend or
something but yeah regardless I did
prepare something for us to check out
Esther after this game as a lot of you
have requested it so here it is this is
something very important for this for
this match so I will read it as a lot of
my viewers are watching this from their
smartphones or mobile devices but you
can also just pause the video here and
read it yourself or you can simply skip
it if you know you're not into
increasing your vast knowledge but for
those of you who are interested this is
something we already used as a quote
until the match with Fischer in 1971
everything went smoothly in my chest
career this dramatic match changed my
life into hell says Mark Temenos
as Fischer himself admitted at the time
the final score did not reflect the true
balance of strength the terrible feeling
that I was playing against the machine
which never made any mistake shattered
my resistance Fisher would never concede
any weakening of his position he was an
incredibly tough defender the third game
proved to be the turning point of the
match after a pretty technical sequence
I had managed to set my opponent serious
problems in a position that I considered
to be winning I could not find a way to
break through his defenses for every
promising idea I found an answer for
Fisher I lost myself in a very deep
thing which did not produce any positive
result frustrated and exhausted I
avoided the critical line in the end and
lost the threat of the game which led to
my defeat eventually this he talks about
the Queen h3 move in game 3 which he did
not play which would most likely lead to
a much better game and he really went he
really did well in positions like that
so if he played it it's hard to say what
would happen but it would be a much
better line than the one he played
returning the knight back to f3 10 years
later I found at last how I should have
wounded a fatal game but unfortunately
it did not matter anymore I have written
a book about this match entitled how I
became fishers victim it represents an
essay on the American player and
described describes how I perceived his
style and personality once the match was
over once the match was over the
sanctions from the Soviet government
were severe I was deprived of my civil
rights my salary was taken away from me
I was prohibited from travelling abroad
and censored in the press I was
unthinkable for the authorities that it
was unthinkable for the authorities that
the Soviet Grandmaster could lose in
such a way to an American without a
political explanation I therefore became
the object of slander and was accused
among other things of secretly reading
books of Southampton I can't really read
that I was banned from society for two
years it was also at the time it was
also the time when I separated from my
first wife duo Brooke so that being said
I do hope you enjoyed that but for those
of you who really want to increase your
vast knowledge there is also something
we must include here this is an
interview with Timon of Scotch at
time every any of us you cook who
prepared him for his game against Bobby
Fischer so I will also read that I will
put a link to it in the description
below where you can check it out but
it's from a Russian website this is
something that was sent to me by
subscriber a via email in English so the
start with how it became time on of
strainer mark and I have played in an
international tournament in Reykjavik
that was held in 1968 we by the way
shared first and second place gathering
10 and 1/2 points out of 15 we got along
in Iceland and established friendly
relations says Afghani was Yukos right
before the USSR championship has started
in 1969 the one that would qualify
qualify the participants for the
mallorca am i or painters on all
tournament mark and I have agreed that
the one who would qualify for the
Interzone would stake another one as a
coach the amount of head luck he
defeated luta Cove in the last round
arounds puzzling game and we went to my
Orca de Manos performance in my Orca was
also successful he shared 56 place with
woman and won the rights to play in the
candidates matches so just think of it
his opponent in the quarter-final was
Fischer who has scored an excellent
result in my Orca gathering 18 Atta and
half out of 23 and easily took clear
first leaving his rivals Geller and
Larson they've shared second and third
place three and a half points behind now
he would face the hardest trial the
match against Fischer in Vancouver our
preparation was very good with analyzed
Americans 500 games on the basis of this
material with composed Fischer's
creative portrait our characteristic of
Fischer was approved by both Vinick who
called it deep and correct in short I
believe that the mono was well prepared
for the match we together with them on
of wins the Canada I as a second and AUD
balashov who specially studied fisheries
work as a coach the Grandmaster
Alexander cutoff headed the delegation
so as you can see atamanov had a lot of
support from the Soviets and he was very
well prepared the match has started the
man of loss the first game the second
game was adjourned in the worst position
but when the game was resumed we caught
Fischer on a trick and the game was
again adjourned in an absolutely drawn
position the day of the third game came
during the preparation I found an
improvement in the variation of King's
Indian which has been played by Fisher
so the man have got a comfortable
position after applying it we saw an
almost knocking out move but time passed
and mark didn't play it eventually tired
of calculations the amount of made a
wrong move Fischer intercepted the
initiative and won the game diamond was
so depressed after this loss that he
blundered and lost in the in the resumed
second game the see the score of the
match showed zero to three and then it
became a one-sided contest Fischer grew
stronger as the match progressed what a
man who had just thrown away his rook in
the fifth game as a result a whitewash 0
to 6 why did that happen of course
Fischer was much stronger but as even he
has admitted the final result of the
match did not illustrate the real
correlation of forces tamaño had to lose
but not in such a crushing manner a
significant role in this fiasco played
Temenos
malnutrition during this match Oh owing
to which he just physically couldn't
stand the workload so this is something
what you who wants us to to know he was
malnourished because he wanted to save
money in order to buy some things he
couldn't buy in USSR as long as I knew
that Mark had a rare appetite I noticed
that he was malnourished so I told him
that he shouldn't be economizing
economizing on food that it's very
important for being able to stand 5 hour
attention during the game fortunately we
the members of the delegation received
from the Sports Committee of USSR the
normal daily substance for those times
11 American dollars per each while
tamaño was getting even more from the
organizer of the match millionaire
apprentice so he could eat properly not
denying oneself anything so a very
interesting that you know the Soviet
Union gave at the amount of seconds and
coaches 11 dollars per day so I know
times were different but that really
does not sound much however he didn't
pay attention to me and continued saving
he never visited the restaurant out of
over 5-star Hotel which was a one-story
lower during the match balashov and I
having a kitchen in our room were buying
all kinds of products in the supermarket
and fed up excessively economical mark
does it sound like nonsense yes
unfortunately that
happened so here we have we had a nice
interview with taimanov and also a nice
interview with a vegan in my soup of who
was tomorrow's coach and mentor for this
match against Fischer so a lot of things
could have played a role but regardless
of all of this I don't think that you
are you will be able to win against such
a strong player like mark the amount of
you know which anything other than
simply being better okay perhaps zero to
six is is a bit unrealistic but I mean
you all saw the games you also how well
Fischer played I mean it's I just wanted
you to see this so you could you know
this side for yourselves but yeah it's
also a famous saying if the amount of
said after he lost zero to sixty Bobby
Fischer he said at least I still have my
music as both him and his wife Luba
Brooke were were pianists so here is a
photo of them playing pianos and I will
also include two links in the
description below where you can listen
to a song on a piano played by Mark
Temenos and his wife and perhaps I know
I have no idea who these channels belong
to but you know feel free to write
something nice for tomorrow as he really
produced some wonderful games against
Fischer regardless of the 0 to 6 result
so III hope i covered the 1971
candidates match vs at amount of fairly
well I do hope you enjoyed it and that
you will keep enjoying the series we are
now heading into the 1971 candidates
match Fisher versus bent Larsen his his
old nemesis so yeah it's gonna be it's
gonna be very interesting and yeah I
would like to thank ingenious that I
played far as Hector Coronado Christo
Carrasco and kuanysh ran back home for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here I think all for watching I'm
gonna check out a couple of your
suggestions see what's happening in the
chess world and then we're just gonna
continue with our Bobby Fischer series
thank you all and I'll see you soon